seriously
excuse me I just got off the phone yeah
huge get Ross of the game grumps is
gonna be here to give us advice on
YouTube
it's insane he's got so many I know he's
here guru say you bought the boy hey
how's it going mark yeah my belonging
that longer atomic of Mark Clark what no
markiplier
Mars nice we've someone's has channels
no I'm actually a little yeah well I
mean but I mean if you know but good I'm
here to help you with your YouTube
channel my name's Ross from game grumps
great show
have you seen any what's your favorite
episode boys nice good mates all good do
you like her what kind of money judge
steel I tried five smae coming out your
lip very [ __ ] funny boys you know
what else is funny
big old blood sliced all right here tell
you what you know what we could do
combine them you get big old fat bottoms
and big old funny thoughts you can bind
that to you get big old sumo wrestlers
running around doing thoughts fighting
sumo excellence
you want more all right let me tell you
boys do you like gaming you like video
games do you want to static a dude in
the face will I tell you what what's
something that everybody loves to do and
just all the time driving mate we all
got yes we all drive so what are we
gonna do night big channels on YouTube
like that um mcmerkin over there easy
just one that would let's drive channel
hello everybody my name is markiplier no
for you boys then that's alright I'll
tell you what there was a video I saw on
the internet like a month or two ago it
was about what people are making out
with smoking other people but they
[ __ ] didn't even know each other then
they [ __ ] know each other you saw
that video well I tell you what we're
gonna make it again but this time we're
going to be combining the pure passion
of kids react you know that show where
they show the kids that video and they
like say you know [ __ ] that one and
then we [ __ ] we combine the two
stranger baby make out where are we
gonna get to baby where are we gonna get
two [ __ ] babies what kind of sick I
am a you're [ __ ] disgusting you are
I tell you what it's not a baby kissing
a [ __ ] baby it's a big bloke kissing
a little bloke on the [ __ ] lips nah
you understand me
the few guys then I understand I
understand I'll tell you what
which one of you boys looks do gods yeah
which one of you boys loves penis what
site with me stay with me new marriages
next buddy's guys show on the Internet
don't buy the [ __ ] penis look these
are very interesting very great ideas I
don't think they're gonna work fantastic
ideas not for us what we're just it's we
have a very different style you know
like it's everything I don't know
another direction me and now I
understand I understand a little too Lou
to go mainstream believe all its I
understand
stead now I'll tell you what this next
audience by five no what do you [ __ ]
me no do you know you are also turning
from the guy votes
oh I am a heated cool you are beneath me
I am superior how about these our dear
human slinky
blinking [ __ ] you you guys don't
appreciate my ideas
gee you guys are never gonna like your
big party and you are never gonna work
in the top EU top EU top of you again
that's the web wide world
ah
the all bad ideas